[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt ich habe versprochen dass
ich euch mal zeigen wie man einen
plunder teig erstellt und das werde ich
genau heute machen und ihr seht
wahrscheinlich schon im hintergrund dass
sich meine küche schon ein bisschen
verändert hat endlich geht's dem ende zu
und sie wird fertiggestellt hoffentlich
alles noch diese woche und ich möchte
den plunder teig machen das ist eine
mischung aus hefeteig und blätterteig
und ich mache diesen aber vereinfacht
also normalerweise bereitet man ein
hefeteig zu und nimmt sich dann in
butter und packt das in so ein stückchen
zusammen
anschlag das in den teig ein und muss es
dann rollen und diese touren machen das
mache ich auch aber dieser tag ist sehr
einfach herzustellen weil ich einfach
den teig mit die weil ich einfach die
butter mit in den tag hinein arbeite und
das zeige ich euch jetzt einfach mal
es gibt natürlich auch 100 fertig zu
kaufen das habe ich in meinem letzten
video gezeigt als ich den akk fleisch
kranz gemacht habe oder diesen ring
besser gesagt aber auch gehabt meine
österreichischen zuschauer haben wir
gefragt wie man den selber machen kann
weil es den bei ihren gar nicht gibt und
deswegen zeige ich euch das jetzt und
zeige euch einfach mal die zutaten an
zutaten habe ich hier 130 millimeter
warmes wasser 120 milliliter milch die
ist ganz normal bei zimmertemperatur
zwei teelöffel salz zwei teelöffel
zucker 15 gramm hefe 300 gramm butter
die habe ich schon in kleine stücke
geschnitten die es noch ganz kalt und
500 gramm mehl da habe ich jetzt wieder
das 550 e mail
also das mit den besseren
backeigenschaften es geht aber auch 405
armeen also ein ganz normales weizenmehl
zuerst müsst ihr jetzt das mehl mit der
butter vermissten das mache ich jetzt in
so einem mixer damit ihr das richtig gut
sehen könnt da kommt jetzt die kalte
butter dazu und das werde ich jetzt
schön miteinander vermischten aber so
dass ich immer noch stückchen von der
butter mit drin hab also bitte nicht
komplett vermixt wir brauchen noch die
butter in stücke
also ich hab das jetzt einfach mehrmals
auf höchster stufe und wieder aus und
ihr könnt hier sehen hier habe ich noch
keine butter stückchen mit drin
und genauso brauchen wir das auch
jeweils bereits die milch mit dem wasser
und mit der hefe vermischen
die brücke ich hier einfach hinein wo es
um damit sie sich auflöst es geht hier
auch salz und zucker hinzu und jetzt
gebe ich hier diese mail mischung dazu
mit der gute und jetzt rührt ihr das mit
einem kochlöffel mit seinem bug löffel
durch geht auch mit einem teig schaber
einfach bis es sich grob vermengt wir
wollen da jetzt nicht mit den händen
rein weil wir den teig nicht wahrhaben
möchten und die mutter soll ja noch ein
stückchen bleiben
zum schluss neben dir dann die hände
ganz schnell und drückt den teig einfach
zusammen gibt es mal kurz auf die
arbeitsfläche
jetzt drücken wir einfach so lange bis
der teig sich gut verbunden hat das
reicht schon
also da muss jetzt nicht komplett
verbunden sein geht ja auch gar nicht
weil wir mal wer die butter stückchen
mit drin haben
dann bereite ich mir jetzt hier etwas
folie vor und geht da einfach den teig
drauf den packe ich jetzt gut ein dass
er nicht austrocknet
und so gebe ich ihnen jetzt für
mindestens zwei stunden in den
kühlschrank
ich hatte den teig geht es zweieinhalb
stunden im kühlschrank und so sieht er
jetzt aus das ist das ergebnis jetzt
fertig ihn auf packen
jetzt kommt der teil mit den touren also
auch bei diesem vereinfachten zeit wird
es so gemacht
der unterschied zum normalen datei ist
einfach dass wir jetzt keine butter am
stück mit einem kneten müssen
mit einfachen müssen sondern dass wir
die butter jetzt mit dem teig drin haben
bisschen mehl auf die arbeitsfläche
dort habt lebt natürlich etwas war ja
die butter stückchen auch außen am tag
dran sind und jetzt versuche ich den
teig auszurollen
manchmal ein bisschen platt drücken
jetzt einfach in die länge rollen
[Musik]
jetzt sehe ich ihn mir ein bisschen in
form sodass ein rechteck ergibt und
jetzt lege ich den teig hier zum drittel
und klappt dieses teil darüber jetzt
drehe ich den teig um 90 grad hier
natürlich auch mir und ich drehe ihn so
dass ich jetzt die offene seite hier
habt ihr richtig geschlossene seite und
jetzt wiederhole ich das noch mal und
wieder das gleiche wieder zum drittel
legen andere seite oben drauf wieder um
90 grad drehen
hier ist jetzt wieder die offene seite
und das ganze noch mal und jetzt lege
ich den tag hier in die mitte hier auch
in die mitte und falte ihn jetzt
zusammen
dann habe ich da oben jetzt keine naht
mehr und habe ein schönes päckchen
drückst du einmal noch flach und so
werde ich jetzt dieses teig paket 1
packung
[Musik]
so kommt der teig jetzt einfach für vier
stunden noch mal in der kühlschrank am
besten über nacht und soweit nicht das
jetzt tun
ich hatte jetzt mal einen tag über nach
dem kühlschrank und wir sehen können ist
ja auch etwas aufgegangen und ich lasse
ihn jetzt einfach kurz hier an der
arbeitsplatte stehen bitte ich meine
erfüllung zubereitet habe und ich habe
mich heute für eine vegetarische füllung
entschieden
um genau zu sein für eine kartoffel
füllung der teig bleibt jetzt einfach
liegen und darf sich noch ein bisschen
ausruhen und ich zeige euch einmal die
zutaten für die kartoffel füllung habe
ich hier bereits kartoffeln abgekocht
das war ein kilo kartoffeln
ich habe jetzt hier geschält etwa 800
gramm hier habe ich olivenöl davon
brauche ich sechs bis acht esslöffel 2
zwiebeln etwas pfeffer zum halben wunsch
petersilie
ihr seht es ist so viel mich fragen
manchmal leute wie viel ist dann ein
bund nimmt einfach so ein bisschen
petersilie in die hand und das reicht
dann auch zwei teelöffel salz 1
esslöffel oregano und ein großer
teelöffel chilipulver das netz die vom
vom türkischen supermarkt die sind nicht
so extrem scharf deswegen nehme ich das
auch so viele ihr müsst auf jeden fall
wieder die backform vorbereiten
das mache ich jetzt wieder mit meinem
back trends prärie und dazu muss sich
ergänzen
ich hab gestern fehler gehabt im video
und zwar ist es wirklich rein pflanzlich
das sind pflanzliche öle und
pflanzliches warstein bienenwachs drin
deswegen ist auch vegan weil es kein
bienenwachs drin zu unseren pflanzen
wachsen
also ich war mir recht sicher dass das
macht bienenwachs riecht aber wie ihr
sehen könnt alles pflanzliche öle und
pflanzliche und pflanzliches wachs naja
war ich halte diesen tausch das bereite
ich jetzt kurz vor und sprühen eine
backform ein die brauche ich ja gleich
ich finde es riecht nach bienenwachs
aber das ist einfach ganz normales wachs
ich habe hier meine pfanne
sie wird bereits vorgeheizt und da gebe
ich jetzt sechs bis acht esslöffel öl
rein aber er sex als achter will
brauchen wir nicht und wer jetzt meine
zwiebeln schön fein hacken
das mache ich hier mit dem alles
scheitern ich nehme ja auf diesen groben
aufsatz jetzt habe ich mal den pfeilern
aufsatz und muss jetzt einfach die
zwiebeln ein bisschen kleiner schneit
aber da nehme ich es am besten die
auffangschale und dann gebe ich einfach
die zwiebelwürfel in die heiße pfanne
und jetzt hören wir sie einfach so lange
bis sie glasig gedünstet sind und ihr
fragt mich ja immer nach dieser pfanne
und sie sich jetzt eine keramik pfanne
diesmal geschenkt bekommen habe und ich
kann euch keramik kann leider gar nicht
empfehlen wir hatten auch mal ganz teure
aus dem fernsehen
die waren genauso schlecht und diese
hier ist auch schlecht also ich kann die
euch nicht empfehlen weil der ein oder
andere hat ja schon gesagt auch die
fahne ist so toll die ich wirklich noch
am anfang toll und dann fängt wirklich
alles anzukleben als ich würde sogar
behaupten wasser klebt drin an
mai war da drin in dieser keramik fanden
das ist nicht mal raus gekommen und ich
weiß nicht also ich bin kein fan von
keramik fahren es müsste mich wirklich
jemand des besseren belehren
aber das ist so meiner meinung dazu aber
dazu würde ich jetzt nächste woche ein
video machen ich möchte nämlich ein
video machen mit küchengeräten mit
küchen gadgets die man braucht die man
nicht braucht und ich kann mich da
einfach mal meine empfehlungen sagen und
meine erfahrungen jetzt auch mit den
gegenständen und das würde ich euch
schon alles zusammenpassen
und während die zwiebeln hier glasig
andünsten werde ich schon mal die
kartoffeln die ich schon gespielt habe
einfach etwas klein reiben
jetzt könnt ihr einfach noch die
petersilie fein hacken
jetzt könnte einfach noch die kartoffeln
mit zu den zwiebeln geben
dann gebe ich jetzt direkt noch die
kräuter mit dazu und auch direkt die
petersilie den herd könnt ihr ausschalte
und jetzt einfach nur noch alles schön
vermischen
[Musik]
meine füllung ist jetzt fertig und ich
kann mich jetzt um den teil kümmern und
ihr seht ihr auch schön da ist richtig
schön nochmal aufgegangen
und das ist praktisch ein teig mit dem
er auch croissants machen könnt da würde
ich aber ein bisschen mehr zucker nehmen
um genau zu sein etwa 30 gramm zucker
und das werde ich jetzt ausrollen und
wieder in zwölf dreiecke schneiden
so wie eben bei meinem hackfleisch ring
auch und deswegen mache ich das jetzt
einfach mal im schnelldurchgang
[Musik]
ich schneide jetzt hier zwei ecke weg
weil es wird mir ansonsten zu viel teig
ich habe ja auch gestern nur mit 400
gramm teig verarbeitet
[Musik]
jetzt genau wie gestern einfach etwas
überlappend hinlegen
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt hier wieder mal den eid
funktion ihrer gefunden und mit ihnen
werde ich jetzt die füllung
herausstechen und ihr seht jetzt hier
bereits ich habe jetzt keine zwölf
stücke draufgelegt dieser selbst
gemachte klondike den habe ich jetzt
nicht ganz dünn ausgerollt ich habe ihn
jetzt etwas dicker gelassen und habe mit
93 ecke draufgelegt und die werde ich
jetzt belegen was macht ein bisschen
schaffte das ist vegetarisch
sie sind gespielt habe ich nichts zu tun
außer du glaubst du siehst doch kein
okay dann mache ich noch ein paar magic
das ist so eine knoblauch wurst eine
knackwurst die gibt es auch in kleiner
die geht es sieht so aus dass ich jetzt
so eine kleine verpackung mit 500 gramm
und diese die könnt ihr im rewe im
globus in türkischen läden kaufen also
die marke gibt es auch in ganz vielen
supermärkten der sich jetzt ein fast
vegetarisches rezept ihr könnt natürlich
gern vegetarisch machen aber mein mann
will jetzt unbedingt mit drauf deswegen
lebt ja dann hat auch die sanierung als
es sieht jetzt meine vegetarische
kartoffelsupp blume jetzt so aus und
jetzt werde ich einfach wie gestern den
teig hier drüber klappen und kann das
hier wieder reinstecken
[Musik]
und jetzt bestreicht es hier einfach
wieder mit etwas milch und eigelb und so
sieht jetzt der fast fertige kranz aus
und stehen werde ich jetzt bei 180 grad
ober und unterhitze für etwa 25 minuten
backen
wenn es wieder wie gestern ist dann nur
noch nur 22 minuten
da müsste einfach mal schauen wenn es
schon goldbraun ist dann ist es auf
jeden fall fertig ich bin jetzt auf der
terrasse denn drinnen ist es mir schon
zu dunkel und wir haben auch keine
lampen und jetzt haben wir noch ein
bisschen sondern licht aber die geht
jetzt auch gleich unter
deswegen mache ich jetzt ganz schnell
und zwar ist der ring fertig er sehe
jetzt auch ich habe die theken nicht
ganz runter gedrückt deswegen sie das
jetzt hier nicht ganz so perfekt aus ich
werde jetzt auch nicht mit salat füllen
das habe ich ja gestern schon gemacht
mit dem hackfleisch regen
wir werden den nämlich soll ist bisher
noch abkühlen lassen und dann wird er
einfach bald verzehrt und ich hoffe
natürlich dass euch dieses rezept
gefällt wie ihr gesehen habt knapp 100
eick auch richtig einfach machen und
hier sieht man auch ganz deutlich diese
einzelnen teigschichten und mit diesem
tag kann man übrigens auch die perfekten
platz machen
ich hatte damals in einem video etwas
anders gemacht mit blätterteig aber mit
plunder teil ist das natürlich viel
besser weil dann auch schon aufgeht
ich würde sagen das rezept gibt es auf
meinem blog wenn ihr euch an diesem
plunder herantraut würde ich mich sehr
freuen ihr habt gesehen ist es sehr
einfach nur eben mit etwas wartezeit und
ich wünsche euch auf jeden fall einen
ganz schönen tag wünsche euch eine ganz
schöne zeit und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal wieder fußball
und nicht vergessen nächste woche gibt's
das video mit meinen tops und flops in
der küche also meinen küchenwerkzeug und
das leben uns dann wieder damit diese
war heute die blogger gibt es am sonntag
eingetroffen
raphael orte los geht's
[Musik]